So we've been at restaurants where she said do
you have anything do you have any non-alcoholic
beer? And I'm like...Kristen Bell opened up on
the Kelly Clarkson Show about why she and her
husband Dax Shepard let their children drink
non-alcoholic beer. He is a recovering addict,
but he likes non-alcoholic beer, so he pop one
open, he'd have her on his chest and we'd walk
and like look at the sunset, so as a baby she
was like pawing at it and sometimes she would
like suck on the rim of it, so I think it feels
to her like something special, something daddy.
Known for being open about parenting, they made
headlines in 2021 for their bath time philosophy.
I'm a big fan of waiting for the stink. Once
you catch a whiff, that's biology's way of
letting you know you need to clean it up. Bell
had this to say about critics of her parenting
style. You can judge me if you want, I'm not doing
anything wrong. Yeah. that's your problem. Yep.